[Musique]
avec cette réforme des retraites nous
demandons un effort aux françaises et
aux Français qui consiste à travailler
un peu plus pour garantir le système par
répartition
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro des grands débats pendant une
heure nous allons revivre ensemble
l'examen d'une des grandes lois de ce
second quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron ici
à l'Assemblée nationale alors
aujourd'hui nous allons parler de la
mère des batailles la réforme des
retraites
annoncé pendant la campagne
présidentielle cette réforme fait partie
des priorités du président réélu après
un temps de négociation à l'automne 2022
la réforme est officiellement lancée le
10 janvier 2023 par la première ministre
Elisabeth borne nous voulons le dialogue
nous l'avons montré ces derniers mois
nous sommes ouverts à la discussion nous
la voulons et nous savons ce qu'elle
apporte cette présentation n'est donc
pas un point final nous sommes prêts à
faire encore évoluer notre projet et
cela sera possible grâce à un débat
parlementaire loyal et constructif
la loi prévoit trois mesures principales
le report de l'âge légal de 62 à 64 ans
la suppression des régimes spéciaux et
la revalorisation des pensions minimum
pour faire passer ce texte le
gouvernement va avoir recours à une
procédure particulière une loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale qui
va lui permettre de limiter le temps des
bas au Parlement à l'Assemblée nationale
les députés ne vont ainsi avoir que 20
jours en première lecture pour examiner
la réforme un temps de débat qui va
mettre l'hémicycle sous tension les
débats débutent le 6 février 2023 dans
une ambiance d'emblée électrique
merci
madame la Présidente
messieurs les ministres Gabriel cher
Franck
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales
madame le rapporteur général
mesdames et messieurs et les rapporteurs
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous croyez que nous allons
passer 15 jours comme cela dans les
muscles oui
vous ne croyez pas que nos compatriotes
méritent mieux que ça
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre merci madame la
Présidente
nous y sommes et quand bien même vous ne
le voudrez pas nous y sommes nous sommes
là après plusieurs années de débat des
mois de concertation nourris des
engagements présidentiels
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre
je fais tous mes efforts madame la
Présidente
mesdames et messieurs les députés
je le disais il y a un instant nous y
sommes
la question des retraites nous en
parlons depuis des années nous avons
ouvert une concertation nourrie il y a
plusieurs mois des engagements
présidentiels clairs ont été pris et
donc aujourd'hui nous réformons nos
retraites je suis très je suis très fier
très fier présenté au nom du
gouvernement ce projet de loi qui assure
l'avenir du système de retraite et qui
participe aussi à notre objectif de
plein emploi
mesdames et messieurs les députés c'est
très fort mais elles concrétise les
engagements du Président de la
République il avait fait la promesse de
ce chantier aussi difficile que
nécessaire et cette promesse nous la
tenons aujourd'hui cette réforme j'y
crois profondément j'y crois
profondément car je crois profondément à
la légitimité des yeux urnes celle du
président de la République celle comme
de chacun et chacune des députés
je sais pertinemment que tous ceux qui
l'ont élus ne l'ont pas tous fait pour
soutenir cet engagement d'abord
mais
cet engagement du Président de la
République est un engagement clair qui
participe de l'action du gouvernement
qui manifeste à nouveau son esprit de
responsabilité qui manifeste aussi avec
cette réforme que cela n'était pas un
projet caché qu'il n'y a pas de
tromperie quel président de la
République l'a annoncé l'adite l'as
assumer et nous avec lui cette réforme
était d'ailleurs au coeur de la
déclaration de politique générale de la
première ministre devant vous cet été et
déjà avec ses principes de progressivité
différenciation
je veux vous dire aussi que je crois
profondément qu'avec cette réforme nous
nous inscrivons dans la poursuite de la
transformation du pays et de
l'amélioration de notre modèle social
ces réformes que nous portons depuis 5
ans nous le savons et vous le savez nous
avons été élu pour débarrasser les
Français des contraintes obsolètes des
corporatismes pour fluidifier la société
pour assécher les routes pour continuer
de battre en brèche les déterminismes et
pour mettre un terme aux assignations à
résidence et pour tout cela nous avons
une conviction cette conviction c'est
celle de la majorité mais c'est aussi la
conviction bien au-delà de tous les
bancs nous pensons que le travail le
travail et la meilleure des armes le
meilleur outil le meilleur levier pour
donner de l'autonomie de la dignité pour
lutter contre la pauvreté pour financer
notre modèle social
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la Présidente en vérité la politique
c'est prendre ses responsabilités pour
soi et pour les autres c'est donner une
direction à l'action collective c'est le
faire dans un cadre républicain c'est ce
que je vous propose de faire avec ce
texte et je compte sur vous pour
qu'ensemble nous soyons à la hauteur cet
enjeu
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Gabriel Attal
ministre délégué chargé des comptes
publics
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente
messieurs les ministres madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales madame la rapporteur général
mesdames et messieurs les députés
nous voilà à l'heure des choix nous
voilà à cet instant où vous avez vous
parlementaire à vous saisir d'un projet
de loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale permettant de garantir
l'équilibre et donc la viabilité de
notre système de retraite nous voilà à
l'heure où sur l'intérêt électoral il
faudra faire primer l'intérêt général
défendre l'intérêt général ce n'est rien
de moins que défendre les Français agir
et œuvrer pour eux et parfois c'est le
faire en allant contre son propre
intérêt politique ou partisan du moment
contre sa popularité de l'instant en
privilégiant l'action et le mouvement
plutôt que le surplace et la facilité
nous voilà à l'heure des choix je le
disais le choix entre l'intérêt général
et l'intérêt électoral le choix en le
entre le courage et la facilité le choix
entre la vérité et la dissimulation et
bien le choix de cette majorité de ce
gouvernement c'est celui de dire la
vérité et d'agir pour permettre à 20
millions de Français de pouvoir compter
sur une pension de retraite financée par
la solidarité nationale le voilà le
choix qui est le nôtre le choix sur
lequel nous vous proposons de débattre à
compter d'aujourd'hui
après la défense du texte par le
gouvernement les oppositions vont tirer
leurs deux premières cartouches le
rassemblement national et la France
insoumise vont défendre des motions pour
interrompre l'examen du texte
alors je
vous allez en application de l'article
91 alinéa 5 du règlement
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre scolaire
pourquoi avons-nous été élu
nous examinons une réforme des retraites
haïr 80% des Français 93% des actifs
tous les syndicats sont contre près de 3
millions de personnes ont défilé dans
les ruches mais vous souhaitez passer en
force
pourquoi avons-nous été élu
pas pour brutaliser le peuple monsieur
le ministre pourquoi avons-nous été élu
pas pour discuter en 9 jours seulement
de la vie actuelle et future de millions
de Français avec cet article 47 ans vous
détournez la Constitution vous piétinez
la démocratie parlementaire ce sera 50
jours de débats en tout avec la
possibilité d'utiliser le 49.3 ou
d'adopter le texte sans vote et par
ordonnance monsieur le ministre votre
jusqu'au-boutisme à quelque chose de
forcené vous paraît cadiez toutes les
issues et espérer solder le bras de fer
dans l'hémicycle mais ces murs ne sont
pas assez épais pour vous protéger de la
colère qui s'élève au dehors et pendant
l'examen du texte les Français n'en
n'auront pas fini avec vous avec cette
motion de rejet nous vous donnons
l'occasion d'arrêter le chaos délibéré
le vote de cette motion de rejet ne fera
pas plus de vous en insoumis qu'un
membre de la nupesse mais un simple
opposant à la réforme de retraite à 64
ans Emmanuel Macron un simple opposant
au vol organisé de deux ans de vie comme
la majorité des Français
votons en conscience gardons à l'esprit
que le peuple nous regarde honorons le
mandat que nous avons reçu de lui
je mets au voile à motion de rejet
préalable je vous prie de bien vouloir
regagner vos places
[Applaudissements]
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin et clos pour 243 contre 292
l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas adopté
j'ai reçu en application de l'article
122 du règlement une motion pendant à
proposer de soumettre au référendum le
projet en discussion donc la parole est
à Monsieur Sébastien Chenu pour
présenter la motion merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur les ministres
j'allais dire madame la Première
ministre mais elle ne nous fait pas la
grâce de sa présence mesdames et
messieurs les députés chers collègues en
jeu central d'une société une réforme
des retraites doit être débattue à la
lumière du sort qu'elle réserve à ceux
qui ont contribué le plus durement à
construire notre pays notre modèle
social a ainsi permis l'amélioration des
conditions de vie des retraités jusque
dans les années 90 mais à mal par les
dernières réformes néolibérales ce n'est
plus le cas aujourd'hui la réforme des
retraites qui est devant nous
aujourd'hui est refusé par une majorité
de Français combattue et pour une simple
et bonne raison elle est profondément
injuste sa logique comptable ça boussole
idéologique qui se soumet à une demande
de l'Union européenne amènerait ainsi
ceux qui ont travaillé plus tôt plus dur
plus longtemps a contribué plus
fortement que les autres
vous êtes chers collègues des
adversaires politiques avant ce vote et
vous le demeurerez après ce vote mais
vous allez devoir faire preuve d'une
liberté intérieure et personnelle de
cette forme de courage que préférons
toujours les Français au manoeuvre
d'arrière boutique comment chers
collègues revenir en circonscription en
assumant de privés les Français de
choisir leur avenir comment être
crédible alors même que nos textes nous
livrent sur un plateau un outil qui
permet ce choix chers collègues je vous
le répète ne nous laissons pas ne
laissons pas les futiles batailles
politiciennes entacher la liberté de
notre peuple à s'opposer de lui-même à
cette réforme à disposer de son avenir
je ne suis d'aucune faction je l'ai
combattrai toutes déclarait proclamait
Robespierre écartons nos divergences
relevons ce défi du référendum faisons
valoir nos différences devant les
Français et faisons confiance
à nos compatriotes pour trancher à eux
le dernier mot devant le choix des
Français inclinons-nous
je vais donc mettre voir cette motion
référendaire tout le monde a pu regagner
sa place
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin et clos pour 101 contre 272
l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas adopté
[Applaudissements]
l'émotion ayant été rejetée à l'issue de
la discussion générale les députés
entables l'examen de la loi problème les
députés d'opposition en particulier de
gauche ont déposé une montagne
d'amendements 20 000 au total dès le
début et l'article 1 les débats sans
lisent ainsi sur la question des régimes
spéciaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le fait qu'aujourd'hui les régimes
spéciaux tel qu'ils existent sont avant
tout les frais d'une histoire les frais
d'une histoire qui ont parfois été
rappelés des époques qui parfois ont
justifiées que certaines professions
puissent faire l'objet d'une protection
particulière mais qui aujourd'hui ne se
justifie plus et qui ne se justifie plus
notamment par les coûts cela peut
représenter merci monsieur le Président
on n'est pas bien là dans l'idéologie
pure absolue total
détendu du service public tranquille
on supprime les on supprime les
régimes spéciaux uniquement pour ceux
qui arrivent aucun effet sur la retraite
en plus les gens qui bénéficient des
régimes spéciaux sur cotisent donc aucun
effet sur les financements de la
retraite mais de l'idéologie pure
absolue la RATP manque de chauffeur on
n'arrive pas à prendre les métros elle
est au bord de la rupture allez hop on y
va
l'amendement que nous défendons vis donc
à maintenir le régime spécial des
retraites des secteurs de l'industrie
électrique et gaziaire que vous
souhaitez supprimer alors même que ce
régime est excédentaire partout en
France ce sont près de 140 000 salariés
qui assurent la construction et la
maintenance des unités de production
d'énergie et qui commercialisent ou
distribue l'électricité et le gaz comme
la démontrer la pandémie de covid 19 ce
sont des emplois vitaux pour le
quotidien de nos concitoyens et pour
l'économie nationale il est donc
nécessaire de valoriser de fidéliser
leurs compétences la préservation de ces
régimes spéciales et d'autant plus
importante que nous avons impérativement
besoin de rendre attractif les métiers
relevant du secteur de l'énergie les
salariés de l'industrie
électrique et gazières sont attachés au
service public
ils ont le sens du service public car
ils interviennent 24 heures sur 24 7
jours sur 7 tous les jours de l'année et
ils ne sont pleine pas ils aiment leur
travail ils le font avec plaisir ils le
font même de génération en génération
car chez eux comme chez les cheminots
c'est une vocation d'être gasiée ou
d'être énergéticien il sauve des vies
ils sauvent des vies quand ils
interviennent pour aller réparer une
fuite de gaz décalée décalée révélée ils
ont y compris ils ont y compris le sens
de l'humanité parce que parfois ces
hommes et ces femmes s'en vont rétablir
l'électricité et le gaz à des familles à
qui des entreprises privées leur ont
coupé cette énergie pendant la trêve
inerte hivernale et c'est ce qui s'est
passé cet hiver en dehors de la loi en
toute illégalité et bien eux ils
rétablissent ces gens dans l'électricité
ce sont les Robins des Bois de l'énergie
oui eux ils ont le sens de l'humanité le
rassemblement national qui est attaché
au fait que les Français on aille pas
leur chercher de l'argent dans les
poches c'est son Madame Le Pen tous les
Français qui payent le régime spécial
des salariés des EIG c'est ça la vérité
alors alors chers collègues ont reconnu
leur travail on reconnaît la pénibilité
on baissera pas leurs pensions
simplement comme les autres comme les
autres ça sera la clause du grand-père
nous parlons d'un régime qui a
aujourd'hui 140 000 contisants et 175
000 pensionnés ce qui explique le
déficit et il est assez simple
d'afficher un excédent
affiché un excédent de 120 millions
quand le régime bénéficie d'une taxe
affectée d'un milliard 7 c'est plus
facile d'être un excédent quand on a un
milliardet de taxes affectés payés par
les consommateurs sur chaque facture que
quand on a pas de taxe affectées et donc
il y a une volonté d'équité madame le
rapporteur l'a dit pour le flux le flux
c'est 4600 Bosch par an et il y a une
volonté à terme évidemment de retrouver
du pouvoir d'achat en supprimant les
taxes affectés et donc c'est la raison
pour laquelle la vie est évidemment
défavorable à ses amendements de
suppression
on vient de perdre une heure une heure
de débat une heure par la de la
responsabilité de l'obstruction de la
nupesse est-ce que vous vous demandez
sérieusement à quoi vous servez est-ce
que vous le matin vous vous avez le
sentiment d'être utile d'être utile aux
Français d'être utile au débat des utile
sur la réforme des retraites vous nous
empêchez de débat du fond du sujet vous
êtes encore une fois les alliés de la
macronie
vous vous rendez compte que depuis tout
à l'heure vous êtes dans des amendements
identiques même les exposés sommaires
sont identiques alors je sais que vous
défendez le droit à la paresse le droit
à l'appareil on le voit toujours les
mêmes toujours les mêmes arguments
toujours les mêmes amendements vous ne
servez strictement à rien nous allons
donc je mettrouvoir l'article premier
nous allons donc maintenant procéder au
scrutin je vous prie de bien vouloir
gagner vos places
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
votant 346 exprimaient 344 majorités 173
pour 181 contre 163 l'Assemblée
nationale a adopté
[Applaudissements]
alors que les débats s'enlisent un
épisode va encore ralentir leur rythme
une photo publiée par un député de la
France insoumise sur les réseaux sociaux
va susciter une vague de réprobation
dans l'hémicycle monsieur les ministres
calmez-vous collègues il y a pas de
ballons ici
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
soyez pas étonné mon cher collègue soyez
pas étonné
je suis très appart
allez
un peu de silence s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
monsieur porte
je crois que l'hémicycle vous demande
des excuses
madame Aurore berger la présidente
berger pour un rappel au règlement merci
madame la Présidente sur le fondement
aussi de l'article 70-5 nous ne
laisserons passer aucun comportement qui
dégrade notre Assemblée nationale aucun
comportement nous exigeons des excuses
de votre part pour les promos que vous
avez eu l'attitude provocatrice qui est
la vôtre nous ne laisserons rien passer
jamais
la parole est au président Marc Angeli
pour un rappel au règlement merci sur le
fondement de l'article 70 mon cher
collègue je respecte vos convictions
elles sont respectables mais vous devez
retirer ce tweet c'est obligé vous ne
pouvez pas poser avec votre écharpe vous
ne pouvez pas vous ne pouvez pas faire
ça vous ne pouvez pas faire ça pour la
solennité des débats dans cette maison
vous ne pouvez pas faire ça pour les
idées que vous défendez vous n'avez pas
conscience de la violence de cette image
et c'est grave
soyez humain soyez responsable soyez
démocrate retirez votre tweet
je vous remercie
monsieur porte est-ce que
[Musique]
non allez-y allez-y alors
vous retirer cette réforme qui va
sacrifier des milliers de gens voilà
je vous indique compte tenu de ce qui
est en train de se passer dans
l'hémicycle de l'absence d'excuse de
monsieur porte qui provoque
manifestement un tumul dans cette
assemblée je convoque un bureau
immédiatement et monsieur porte donc
vous allez être vous y êtes convoqué
également pour y être entendu la séance
est suspendue
[Applaudissements]
après cet épisode une très longue
suspension de séance qui aboutira à des
sanctions contre les députés l'examen
reprend et les députés peuvent enfin
voter l'article 1 qui supprime les
régimes spéciaux ils en viennent alors à
l'examen de l'article 2 ils ont déjà
consommé quatre jours de débat un
article qui concerne l'emploi des
seniors
alors j'ai des inscrits à l'article
madame faussillon pour le groupe GDR
merci madame la Présidente nous allons
commencer à aborder cet article 2 que
nous pourrions renommer l'article écran
de fumée par cet article vous proposez
la création d'un gadget d'un gadget
aussi inutile qui efficace vous le savez
ces outils inopérants auxquels nous
sommes maintenant habitués venant de
vous n'ont que très peu voir aucun effet
nous n'avons qu'à regarder l'index
parité femme homme que vous avez créé en
2018 d'après les chiffres de votre
propre gouvernement avant sa mise en
place nous étions à 25% de parité
vis-à-vis des rémunérations entre les
femmes et les hommes avec l'index 27%,
cela ne fonctionne pas même chose avec
les obligations d'emploi des
travailleurs handicapés alors qu'il
existe des sanctions financières seuls
29% des entreprises selon la Dares
respecte leurs obligations en matière
d'embauche de travailleurs handicapé
pire encore toujours selon la Dares 31%
des entreprises
embauche aucun salarié handicapé et le
comble avec c'est index au senior c'est
que les sanctions prévues par cet
article ne s'appliquent pas aux
entreprises qui ont de mauvais résultats
mais seulement aux entreprises qui ne
publient pas leurs résultats il a deux
objectifs de mon point de vue il a
d'abord l'objectif de responsabiliser
les employeurs
cette responsabilité elle passera par la
publicité des résultats la deuxième
finalité de cette index et j'en termine
avec cela et bien c'est de permettre à
toutes celles et tous ceux qui sont au
chômage et qui ont dépassé un certain
âge de mieux chercher et de cibler les
entreprises qui jouent le jeu de
l'emploi des seniors ça c'est un élément
très important et j'espère que l'index
permettra également d'atteindre cet
objectif des propositions très concrètes
émanent soit de cette assemblée soit
l'Institut diverses et variés pourtant
ce n'est pas
la bonne façon d'étudier la question des
retraites la question de l'allongement
de la durée de vie active elle enjeu de
toute réforme des retraites il y a des
freins il y a des blocages il faut en
sortir une personne sur deux prend sa
retraite alors qu'elle est sans emploi
de notre pays ça doit être une cause
majeure une cause politique qui doit
nous rassembler et dans ce texte portant
sur les retraites nous avons quoi comme
réponse un index
un indicateur de la pratique ou pas des
entreprises monsieur le ministre sur un
sujet comme celui-ci il faut des moyens
un océan tracasseri administratif vous
avez bien résumé les choses monsieur le
ministre parce que a-t-on vraiment
besoin de faire peser encore un peu plus
de contraintes sur nos entreprises je
vous rappelle quand elles ont du mal à
payer leur facture d'énergie lors de
leur imposer de de cette contrainte
administrative supplémentaire d'un index
des seniors ça me semble pas forcément
une très très bonne idée je suis de
cette génération concernée au premier
rang par votre réforme et je suis en
colère aujourd'hui entre 50 et 60 ans
mes amis les gens de mon âge redoutent
de perdre leur emploi quand ils en ont
encore un redoutent de grossir à court
terme les rangs des 40% de travailleurs
seniors hors de l'emploi malgré leur
dévouement et leurs compétences
est-ce qu'un index de l'emploi des
seigneurs est une démarche utile oui car
elle va donner de la visibilité
médiatique à ce sujet notamment pour les
plus grosses entreprises est-ce que
l'index tel qu'il est prévu est
suffisant nous ne le pensons pas au
groupe démocrates il doit être incitatif
car on ne peut pas passer d'un d'une
période où il y avait des sangles on se
servait de l'emploi des seigneurs comme
d'une variable d'ajustement à une
période où ça serait coercitif il faut
être incitatif la question qui se pose
c'est qu'est-ce que l'on fait lorsqu'une
entreprise a satisfait ses obligations
de publicité lorsqu'il y a eu
négociation mais qu'il n'y a pas
d'amélioration de la situation qu'il n'y
a pas de mise en place d'action
correctrices dans ce cas là nous
prévoyons des mesures de sanction des
mesures coercitives avec des actions
obligatoires ou des sanctions
financières qui seront fixées par décret
et il y a dans cette question des
seniors le point central de la question
vous allez retirer les deux meilleures
années de via la retraite celle où on
est encore en bonne santé pour les
substituer par les deux années les plus
difficiles de l'adjectif puisque on s'y
retrouve une fois sur deux dans une
situation de précarité et de et de
non-emploi en réalité vous prenez les
choses totalement à l'envers puisque la
loi que vous nous promettez devrait être
en réalité être une loi qui précède
éventuellement une réforme des retraites
parce que si on augmente le taux
d'emploi des seniors de 10%, il n'y a
plus besoin de faire votre retraite
l'index senior donc ainsi que
l'obligation de négocier un accord de
gestion de des emplois et des parcours
professionnels ne concerne que les
entreprises de plus de 300 salariés dans
un premier temps c'était même 1000 donc
ces entreprises ne représentent que 39%
des salariés du secteur privé donc on
propose de baisser le seuil de 300 à 50
dans ce cet amendement pourquoi est-ce
que nous retenons cet indice c'est index
à partir de 50 parce que c'est le seuil
au-delà de laquelle nous sommes plus
dans une petite entreprise nous
commençons d'être dans une moyenne
entreprise et nous devons finalement
faire un choix entre deux seuils 50 et
300 5300 parce que 300 dans le code du
travail c'est le seuil à partir duquel
il existe un certain nombre
d'obligations légales en matière
dialogue social et la lisibilité
commande plutôt de choisir entre un
seuil à 50 et un seuil à 300 plutôt qu'à
aller chercher un seuil qui a une
identité essentiellement économique
autour de 150
voici le résultat du scrutin votant 379
exprimer 368 majorité 85 pour 272 contre
96 il est adopté et il fait tomber les
amendements suivants cette réforme est
l'augmente presque automatiquement le
taux d'emploi des seniors on l'a vu en
2010 on a un exemple voilà le taux
d'emploi des seniors il a évidemment
augmenté et c'est une bonne chose c'est
une bonne chose pour la France et je
pense que c'est une bonne chose d'une
manière générale pour le pouvoir d'achat
des Français votre index senior ça n'est
qu'une feuille de salade
de Morien au goût du au goût du plat
c'est juste un décor pour nous faire
croire qu'il y a la moindre contrainte
sur les entreprises alors que
profondément il n'y en a que sur les
salariés et sur leur corps
[Applaudissements]
alors que les débats durs un nouvel
épisode va encore les ralentir
intervenants pour évoquer la question
des accidents du travail le député de la
France insoumise Aurélien saint Toul va
susciter une vague d'indignation dans
l'hémicycle
et puis ce que vous avez voulu parler
des morts du travail je vous donne les
chiffres parce que vous avez menti
encore une fois et comme vous êtes
ministre du fait de votre felloni ça ne
me surprend pas en 2017 en 2017 il y
avait 550 morts dans des accidents du
travail dans ce pays en 2018 il y en
avait 562 en 2019 il y en a eu 733 et je
ne compte pas les accidents de la route
évidemment ce qui signifie qu'entre 2017
et 2019 c'est 33% d'accidents du travail
causant la mort en plus donc vous ne
pouvez pas arriver ici et me dire que la
suppression des CHSCT n'a eu aucun effet
ce sont 150 orphelins doivent veuves en
plus et vous avez la responsabilité de
ses choix politiques vous êtes un
imposteur et un assassin
chers collègues alors
[Applaudissements]
chers collègues ne hurlait pas j'ai
entendu
ne hurlez pas je suspends deux minutes
j'ai des demandes de rappel au règlement
je vais y donner évidemment accès c'est
la présidente berger pour le groupe
Renaissance qui va s'exprimer en premier
j'espère qu'évidemment des excuses
claires et sincères seront présentées
mais vous savez pas des excuses je
m'excuse mais non des excuses point
barre je voudrais dire aussi qu'il faut
ici défendre avec conviction avec
passion parfois avec colère ce à quoi
l'on croit mais jamais avec des mots qui
peuvent blesser ou heurter et moi tu as
un sens et ne peuvent pas dans cette
hémicycle est utilisé à la légère
donc oui ce n'est pas une expression
qu'on peut utiliser ici aucun de nous
n'est un assassin
au nom des députés du groupe la gauche
géographique je tiens à dire à quel
point nous sommes choqués par les propos
qui ont été tenus et j'ajouterai
et j'ajouterai
et j'ajouterai à titre peut-être plus
personnel
que je me sens blessé même humilié je le
dis
je le dis tenir de telles propos est
absolument inacceptable évidemment
l'ensemble de mon groupe souhaite
apporter son soutien à Olivier dups qui
a été très certainement marqué par cette
injure très grave et très lourde vos
idées sont respectables votre combat est
respectable même s'il ne pas partager de
part et d'autre de cette hémicycle mais
de grâce
réfléchissez au poids des mots
réfléchissez à ce qui est ressenti par
les Français en dehors de cette émission
ne peut pas impunément traiter un
ministre un élu un homme une femme
d'assassin parce qu'on n'est pas
d'accord avec lui sur la réforme des
retraites
je proposais à notre collègue symptôme
de prendre la parole
dans le silence voilà on s'écoute merci
monsieur le président
monsieur les ministres mes chers
collègues je souscris en réalité
pleinement aux propos du président Marc
angélique
j'ai eu il y a quelques instants à ce
micro des mots que l'émotion et
l'emportement
m'ont fait mal choisir et qui sont
déplacés je souhaite évidemment les
retirer et adresser des excuses
publiques au ministre et je me tiens à
sa disposition pour avoir un échange
plus personnel et lui présenter à
nouveau mes excuses la seule chose qui
compte pour moi à cette heure c'est que
la réforme puisse être examinée et que
nous puissions aller au fond des choses
et au fond des sujets c'est la seule
chose qui me concerne c'est la seule
chose qui me préoccupe
c'est le député j'entends vous excuses
elles ont le mérite d'être présenté
et elles permettent au débat de se
poursuivre
depuis une dizaine de jours dans
plusieurs de vos interventions vous avez
eu à mon égard entre 10 et 12
qualificatifs que je peux considérer
comme insultant dont un qui a atteint le
paroxysme de l'insulte
j'entends vos excuses mais vous
comprendrez quel traité d'assassin de ce
pardonne pas par contre ces excuses ont
émérite c'est qu'elles permettent au
débattre continuer et c'est mon seul
souhait
[Applaudissements]
après ce nouvel épisode les débats
reprennent enfin sur le fond du texte
alors que la perspective d'examiner
l'article 7 et le report de l'âge légal
s'éloigne les députés entamment un débat
sur l'une des mesures phares de la loi
les pensions minimum monsieur les
ministres ce matin avec mon collègue
Cyril Isaq Sybille je me suis rendu
comme coprésident de la mission
d'évaluation des comptes de la Sécurité
sociale à la Direction de la Sécurité
sociale
cette visite inopinée était motivée par
vos déclarations de la veille monsieur
le ministre selon lesquels le nombre de
personnes bénéficiaires des 1200 euros
vous aviez disez-vous une prévision qui
vous était communiquée qui vous était
arrivée la veille et qui vous indiquait
que 40 000 personnes allaient en
bénéficier
un mois auparavant le 15 janvier c'était
200 000
nouveaux retraités qui allaient
bénéficier de ce minimum de pension j'ai
donc souhaité aller à la source et
questionner la Direction de la Sécurité
sociale pour savoir d'où venait ce
chiffre la direction la sécurité sociale
et je tiens à remercier les hauts
fonctionnaires de qualité qui ont
répondu avec franchise aux questions que
nous posions ont répondu que il n'était
pas à l'origine de ce chiffre et qu'il
ne savait pas eux-mêmes d'où venait ce
chiffre
j'ai fait j'ai fait la même demande
auprès du directeur général de la CNAV
que je rencontrerai y compris tout à
l'heure et la CNAV me dit qu'elle n'a
pas transmis ce chiffre alors Monsieur
le Ministre la question est simple d'où
vient ce chiffre qui est divisé par 4
entre le 15 janvier et le 15 février et
qui sera peut-être à 10000 le mois le
mois prochain par contre un chiffre a pu
mettre communiqué sur ma demande par la
Direction de la Sécurité sociale c'est
le nombre de personnes qui vont
bénéficier des 100 euros c'est à dire du
maximum possible de la revalorisation et
pour la génération 62 l'année prochaine
le chiffre précis qui a été communiqué
et de
13289 personnes qui bénéficieront de
cette revalorisation à 100 euros
c'est-à-dire
1,7% des retraités on ne peut pas avoir
de bons débats si les informations qui
sont transmises au parlementaire ne sont
pas des bonnes informations et donc vous
dès maintenant préciser les chiffres
réels du nombre de bénéficiaires de la
retraite à 1200 euros les sources de ces
chiffres comment ils ont été calculés et
vous devez répondre aux différentes
questions qui sont opposées par le
parlementaire en réalité il se get vous
n'avez rien dit de nouveau rien de neuf
par contre vous avez oublié de dire un
certain nombre de choses et je vais
redire les chiffres que j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de donner nous avons en
France 17 millions de retraités sur ces
17 millions de retraités 200
000 pardonnez-moi je reprends sur ces 17
millions de retraités un million 800000
vont voir leur valorisation leur pension
revalorisées grâce à la mise en place du
minimum de pension
et sur ce million 800 000 900 000 50%.
pour avoir une revalorisation comprise
entre 70 et 80 euros par mois mais vous
êtes tellement déconnecté de la réalité
que vous pensez que pour une petite
pension 70 à 80 euros par mois c'est pas
beaucoup
nous avons
nous avons chaque année
[Applaudissements]
nous avons chaque année 800 000 nouveaux
retraités sur ces 800 000 nouveaux
retraités grâce au minimum de pension
000 200000 vont avoir une pension plus
importante que prévu et j'ai dit sur une
radio qu'en 2030 40 000 retraités
supplémentaires atteindront les 1200
euros et je le maintiens tout comme je
maintiens que si pour la génération 62
la revalorisation maximum pour la
génération 62 en 2024 c'est
effectivement 13000 personnes vous savez
que pour la génération 72 ça sera 40 000
personnes c'est dans l'étude d'impact la
réalité monsieur Guedj c'est que vous
perdez les pédales depuis quelques jours
maintenant vous avez reconnu après des
semaines à nous avoir expliqué qu'il n'y
avait pas de déficit vous avez reconnu
qu'il y a un déficit vous le savez plus
comment faire vous avez mis toute la
coalition autour de la France insoumise
dans l'embarras vous le savez pas
comment vous refaire la cerise la
réalité c'est boostercher un petit
prétexte pour voter contre la
glaugmentation des petites retraites
monsieur le ministre il y a quelques
instants que je perdais
les pédales
je vais vous dire Monsieur le Ministre
et les yeux dans les yeux je vais vous
poser une question
pouvez-vous me dire quand avez-vous eu
communication et par qui d'informations
à l'appui desquelles vous indiquez 40000
personnes qui bénéficieront deuxième
chose vous avez dit pour la première
fois tout à l'heure c'était à l'horizon
2030 sur France Inter hier vous n'avez
jamais prononcé le chiffre de 40000
personnes à l'horizon 2030 et troisième
chose le chiffre de 40000 en effet de la
génération 72 c'est pour le maximum de
100 euros ça ne dit pas le nombre de
personnes qui seront à 1200 euros et je
termine par là la DSS ce matin en me
donnant ces informations m'a indiqué
qu'elle vous avait été transmise à la
mi-janvier et certainement pas
avant-hier soir donc je repose ma
question les yeux dans les yeux vous
avez dit j'ai eu des prévisions
transmises hier pouvez-vous nous dire
quelle administration et quand vous a
transmis les prévisions à l'appui
desquelles vous indiqué que ce sera 40
000 personnes un mot peut-être je
cherche monsieur Guedj en tout cas je
cherche ses yeux mais d'abord pour
retirer une expression malheureuse parce
que elle était un peu grossière et j'en
suis désolé donc je la retire si vous le
voulez bien la deuxième chose c'est que
je n'en tiens rien de ce que j'ai dit
Monsieur Isa Sybille vous l'a dit je
travaille avec mon cabinet je travaille
avec une multitude de services je n'ai
pas honte de compte ni sur les canaux ni
sur la manière dont je fais les
prévisions et si vous y avez si vous
aviez lu l'in le député le député Isa
civil vous a répondu et par ailleurs si
vous souhaitiez avoir ces renseignements
vous aviez comme vous l'avez dit qu'à
ouvrir l'étude d'impact
le Parlement contrôle l'action du
Gouvernement monsieur le ministre vient
de dire qu'il n'avait pas à rendre
compte de quel administration lui avait
donné les informations et les chiffres
rien à quelle date il méprise à côté du
Sion
après ces longs échanges qui pour les
députés d'opposition ont au moins eu le
mérite d'éclaircir les débats on en
vient enfin au vote de l'article 2 sur
la création d'un index senior un vote
qui va réserver une surprise
[Musique]
donc je vous demande de bien vouloir
regagner vos places
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin et clos
votant 467 exprimés 459 majorités 230
pour 203 contre 256 l'Assemblée
nationale n'a pas adopté
après ce camouflé pour la majorité les
oppositions sont revigorées elles vont
attaquer le gouvernement sur un autre
volet de la loi le dispositif sur les
carrières longues
monsieur le ministre du soft la première
ministre lors des questions au
gouvernement il y a quelques heures a
fait une annonce importante sur
l'évolution des carrières longues la
tenue donnée bas nécessite que nous
puissions être informés de tout nous
sommes en train d'examiner de poursuivre
l'examen nous avons compris que le
gouvernement allait déposer au titre de
cet article un amendement hors délais il
est absolument capital pour que nous
puissions poursuivre sereinement les
débats que vous précisiez monsieur le
ministre les choses la première c'est de
bien nous préciser les conditions de cet
amendement a-t-il été déposé d'une part
et s'il a été déposé je vous demande de
répondre à deux questions pouvez-vous
nous assurer que celles et ceux qui dans
le dispositif de carrière longue on
commençait à travailler à 16 ans et à 18
ans partiront bien avec 43 annuités de
cotisation et non 44 comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui et comme semble l'avoir
annoncé la première ministre la deuxième
question que je vous pose monsieur le
ministre et de savoir l'impact financier
de cette mesure-là j'ai cru comprendre
par votre bouche que cette mesure un peu
folle comporter un impact financier de
plus de 10 milliards d'euros il est
capital que la représentation nationale
au moment où elle examine ce texte là
soit informé du périmètre précis de
cette amendement nouveau du gouvernement
hors délais et nous précise l'impact
financier nous en avons besoin pour
continuer à débattre sereinement sur la
suite de ce texte le débat parlementaire
il se fait comme cela les annonces sont
positives manifestement elle mérite
d'être précisée pour ceux qui ont
commencé en carrière longue à 16 ans et
à 18 ans pouvez-vous nous assurer qu'ils
ne feront pas plus de 43 annuités de
cotisation je vous remercie
la première ministre après avoir
travaillé avec de très nombreux
parlementaires de la majorité mais aussi
de votre groupe politique et je pense
notamment à Monsieur cioti comme
responsable de famille politique à
Monsieur Marleix annoncé tout à l'heure
qu'elle avait entendu la nécessité que
dans le cadre des dispositifs de
carrière longue qui aujourd'hui sont
organisés autour de trois bandages 16 18
et 20 ans et puisse y avoir une
quatrième parenthèse sans que cette
bande âge puisse aller au-delà de 21 ans
pourquoi cela parce que ça permet en
créant un quatrième bandage sans que
celle-ci aille au-delà de 21 ans et
c'est ainsi que l'amendement sera rédigé
cela permet d'intégrer dans le
dispositif carrière longue ce qui
commence encore la 20e année et qui lui
fait du relèvement de l'âge c'est amené
à travailler 44 ans monsieur le ministre
le gouvernement a déposé hors délais
hier un amendement pour faire évoluer
manifestement le dispositif des
carrières longues voilà près de 24
heures que nous vous posons incessamment
la même question cet amendement là ne
précise rien sur le dispositif des 16
ans et des 18 ans nous avons tout
entendu sur cet amendement du
Gouvernement il devait coûter 10
milliards d'euros nous ne savons
toujours pas combien il coûte
aujourd'hui le gouvernement a déposé un
amendement dans nous n'avons pas
l'évaluation financière nous vous
demandons de nous répondre pour la
sincérité des débats combien va coûter
d'amendements que le gouvernement a
déposé j'ai bien vu qu'il y a des
accords qui semblent un petit peu
compliqué entre nos collègues
Renaissance et LR et donc je pose une
une question qui est tout à fait
extérieur à leurs enjeux et alors
coalition de briques et de broc est-ce
qu'on pourrait avoir une réponse sincère
comme le prévoit l'alinéa 7 de l'article
100 sur la question suivante pourquoi
certains partiront à 43 d'autres
partiront à 44 et pourquoi deux mois
d'écart d'anniversaire on prend un an en
plus la question a été posée par nos
collègues républicains la question est
posée de manière récurrente par les
groupes de gauche ici présent comment ça
se fait que on commence on aura on devra
cotiser 43 ans quand on a commencé à 18
ans 44 ans quand on a commencé à 19 ans
avec les années père et les années à
faire madame la Présidente nous
demandons à ce que le ministre répondent
qu'il est du temps pour consulter ses
services nous demandons une suspension
de séance pour avoir une réponse au
retour de cette suspension on a une
suspension de séance on la demander pour
avoir une réponse simple est-ce que les
travailleurs perdent les années pairs ou
est-ce qu'il perd de les années impaires
et on a toujours pas de réponse de
ministre
l'amendement déposé par le Gouvernement
sur les carrières longues fait des bas
puisque nous sommes dans l'incapacité de
mesurer l'impact financier de cet
amendement ni même dans l'incapacité de
savoir combien de personnes seraient
concernées par cet amendement de
pacotille je demande donc au titre de
l'article 98 alinéa 1 que le
gouvernement nous éclaire sur
l'évaluation préalable de cette fausse
concession de cette fausse promesse de
cet amendement de pacotille pour que
nous puissions délibérer en toute
connaissance de cause
effectivement
quoi que de la première ministre devant
les députés ce mardi je la cite pour
vous ayez bien en tête j'ai pris un
engagement qui pose le principe dès lors
qui est atteint l'âge de départ anticipé
la réforme ne prévoit pas pour les
carrières longues de durée de cotisation
supérieure à 43 ans et un peu plus tard
les services de Matignon nous ont
transféré un tableau dans lequel on nous
explique ce qui commence à 16 ans
travailleraient 44 ans à 18 ans
c'est-à-dire les bacheliers les
titulaires de cap travailaient 44 ans
mais ce qui commence à 17 ans
travaillerait à 43 ans c'est l'injustice
monsieur a-t-elle voyait bien qu'il y
avait quelque chose ici si vous voulez
des réponses à vos questions sur les
carrières longues c'est assez simple
suffit d'aller à l'article 8 il suffit
de retirer vos amendements et enfin vous
aurez les réponses
on découvre la présence du ministre du
Travail qui jusqu'à maintenant a été
très discret dans cette séance
[Applaudissements]
c'est une bonne nouvelle se réveille
puisqu'il est là on lui demande pour la
sincérité des débats de nous expliquer
pourquoi ceux qui ont commencé à 19 ans
vont devoir travailler 44 années qui
expliquez-nous vous avez fait la roue de
la fortune et c'est tombé sur pas de
chance pour ceux qui ont commencé à 19
ans vous êtes là vous êtes au bord des
ministres vous devez une réponse au
parlementaire avant de passer demain
matin à France Inter
ces débat amènent les députés jusqu'au
terme du temps imparti pour l'examen de
la loi le retrait de plusieurs milliers
d'amendements par les députés de gauche
il suffira pas le vendredi 17 février au
soir c'est la dernière séance le constat
est clair les principaux points de la
loi n'auront pas le temps d'être
examinés ni voté pour beaucoup de
députés le bilan est amer des millions
de personnes
ont eu les yeux braqués sur nous
espérons des réponses
à un projet de loi qui engage leur
avenir
tout ce que nous avons su leur offrir ce
sont des objectifs ce sont des
polémiques stériles à usage interne
les retraites
la durée de cotisations
la pénibilité du travail bien des
questions les seniors bien des questions
auraient pu être traités en examinant
sur le fond quelques centaines
d'amendements points
encore des dizaines de milliers
l'objectif des rédacteurs évidemment
étaient de bloquer le le projet et de
discréditer le gouvernement moi mon
sentiment je vais vous le donner c'est
que c'est Assemblée nationale qui sort
discrédité de ce débats et pire encore
c'est le jeu démocratique qui sort
discrédité de ce débat je le sentiment
que nous avons donné un élan
extraordinaire aux populismes en ayant
extraordinaire
à tout l'entrée parmentarisme en élan
extraordinaire à l'abstention en allant
extraordinaire au parti de l'ordre voilà
la réalité j'espère j'espère de tout mon
coeur que nous n'aurons pas à regretter
tous ces éléments merci
vous savez
le temps passe
dans 10 minutes
les débats seront finis nous vous avez
demandé à plusieurs reprises d'ouvrir
une séance le week-end pour qu'on puisse
continuer ces débats que monsieur le
ministre vient de rouvrir de par le fait
que il n'arrive pas à être clair mais
soyez assuré d'une chose
peut-être que ce soir à l'Assemblée les
débats seront terminés ici nous sommes
150 mais là-bas dehors nous sommes 27
millions de salariés et le débat vient
de commencer chaque collègue il vous
restait deux heures et demie pour
finalement rompre avec le déshonneur que
vous avez eu depuis le début vous avez
méprisé vos alliés vous avez mépriser
vos partenaires vous avez méprisé les
syndicats vous avez mépriser l'Assemblée
nationale vous avez en sorte méprisé les
Français tout au long de cet examen je
pensais que vous étiez un peu moins
insoumis que ça vous êtes soumis à celui
qui n'est même plus député et qui perd
plusieurs fois a été battu à l'élection
présidentielle
on n'est pas rentré dans le fond de la
discussion sur les métiers pénibles
monsieur le ministre et pourtant diocèse
c'était un sujet important qui aurait pu
je pense tous tous nous rassembler
comment on prévient les difficultés que
connaissent les gens qui ont dans des
carrières difficiles dont on sait qu'ils
ne pourront pas aller au bout dans ce
métier comment les reconvertit on n'a
pas parlé des solutions de politique
familiales pour aider les femmes à
continuer leur carrière tout en ayant
des enfants on n'a pas parlé des
questions de la fraude sociale des 1
million 400 000 retraites versées sur
des comptes à l'étranger dans les
Français savent que malheureusement il
n'y a pas assez de contrôle j'espère
monsieur ministre que le Sénat pour
aborder tous ces tous ces sujets
j'espère que vous reprendrez les
amendements que le gouvernement a déposé
je pense notamment la question des
retraites en outre-mer nos compatriotes
d'outre-mer attendaient aussi beaucoup
de ce débat parce que le niveau des
pensions il est bien inférieur je vous
remercie d'avoir accepté de l'amendement
de notre collègue mangeur car mardi qui
permettra de remonter de
à Mayotte et on compte sur le Sénat pour
faire un travail que nous n'avons
malheureusement pas pu faire ici à cause
de député de la France insoumise vous
pouvez apaiser un pays unique contre
votre réforme vous pouvez revenir à la
raison respecter notre démocratie le
Parlement ne pourra pas il reste 6
minutes délibéré sur cette loi parce que
vous avez choisi un calendrier
parlementaire contraint messieurs les
ministres apaiser le pays respecter
notre démocratie respecter les principes
républicains et la République sociale
retirez votre réforme
nous arrivons désormais au terme de
débats
les dispositions la Constitution dans
son article 47-1 et la loi organique
dans son article 111-7 du code de la
sécurité sociale
prévoit que l'Assemblée nationale doit
se prononcer en première lecture dans le
délai de 20 jours après le dépôt du
projet loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale c'est donc dans le respect de la
Constitution que nos débats doivent
désormais prendre soin ce délai s'achève
ce soir les 20500 amendements déposés
par la nuprette auront empêché notre
assemblée d'achever l'examen du texte au
terme de 9 jours de séances et 73 heures
de débats
le gouvernement ne peut pas prolonger
l'examen du texte sans réduire le temps
que le Sénat doit avoir
en application de l'article
elle 110 11-7 du code de la sécurité
sociale l'Assemblée nationale n'ayant
pas émis de vote en première lecture sur
l'ensemble du projet de loi le
gouvernement on saisira le texte le
Sénat du test il a initialement présenté
modifié par les amendements votés par
votre assemblée mesdames et messieurs
les députés insoumis vous m'avez insulté
15 jours vous sortez mais vous m'avez
insulté personne n'a craqué personne n'a
craqué et nous sommes là devant vous
pour la réforme
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
conformément à l'ordre du jour arrêter
ce matin par la Conférence des
Présidents nous allons maintenant
interrompre l'examen du projet de loi je
suspends la séance
après cet examen homérique ici à
l'Assemblée et un passage au Sénat la
loi reviendra au Palais Bourbon une
semaine plus tard l'exécutif décidera
alors de recourir au 49-3 deux motions
de censure seront déposées contre le
gouvernement leur échec signera
finalement l'adoption de la loi par le
Parlement voilà c'est la fin de ce
numéro des grands débats à bientôt sur
LCP
[Musique]